con sus afiladas garras y sus gruesas
crestas de espinas dorsales estas
iguanas de las Islas Galápagos parecen
muy resistentes pero son altamente
vulnerables a los cambios de temperatura
y ahora están amenazadas por el fenómeno
del niño esto se traduce en éxito
reproductivo de estas especies si el
éxito reproductivo de estas especies
golpea su condición poblacional estamos
hablando de un fenómeno del niño en el
ámbito Parque Nacional Galápagos en el
ámbito de conservación con un efecto muy
grave las inusuales altas temperaturas
de las aguas del Pacífico pronostican
tiempos difíciles para los reptiles de
las emblemáticas Islas ecuatorianas y el
fenómeno del niño podría acabar con el
medio de subsistencia de estas iguanas
un tipo de algas marinas que se
encuentran en aguas poco profundas el
principal alimento de las 450.000
iguanas de La Isla el simple cambio en
la temperatura del mar hace que el alga
desaparezca y el alga es el principio de
la cadena trófica para todos los demás
animales del mar Pero principalmente
marihuana que es un es un reptil grande
los expertos climáticos dicen que el
niño trae consigo un clima más extremo
en América Latina afectando al
equilibrio de la fauna y flora de estos
delicados ecosistemas el fenómeno
también trae lluvias intensas al
Pacífico que pone en riesgo la
reproducción de estas tortugas si esas
lluvias son abundantes en frecuencia en
intensidad sus zonas de Nido pudieran
inundarse y si se inundan va a afectar
la reproducción de los nidos
posiblemente a cero el turístico
archipiélago es patrimonio de la
humanidad pero la crisis climática
podría ser el fin de unas especies que
no se encuentran en ningún otro lugar
del mundo